we've got beaches we've got breakups and
we've got burgers it's time for Rosie's
Andros Hey hi you guys oh the blanket
fell so gracefully just then today but
now I'm gonna do this graceful is not my
middle name
hi I'm Lauren thank you guys so much for
joining me to continue to recap cold and
Underwood season of The Bachelor we are
in Thailand we have got beaches I have
never seen so much scenery we had
elephants
we had islands we had oceans
I loved this episode you guys what did
you think overall a great app anytime
they can bring together sexy vibes like
swimsuits and sand along with drama
vibes like fighting and tears I'm an
that's the bachelor at its best right
and look I know you guys want me to be
at my best so a couple of you commented
where's that glass you brought into our
lives that holds an entire bottle of
wine I'm so sorry I'm a disgusting human
I hadn't washed it in a minute but I
brought it right back for you okay now I
did wash it I don't know if you can see
this on the camera lots of like dish
dish detergent spots in it I didn't do a
great job okay not my forte is this
dishwasher safe I don't know I didn't
want to risk it but maybe I should have
and when I say I washed it I'll be
honest a light scrubbing there's still
old lipstick on here anyway what's in
here today I'm putting something I've
never done before you guys this is a
tequila drink I know I know
here's the thing let's get to know each
other even better while I love my wine
while I love my rosy I'll have tequila -
that's my hard liquor of choice and I
thought thank you having a beach
vacation let's make kind of a beachy
drink you know and it's still pink so
let's just all be on the same page and
nobody complains
great okay
just like I've never found a wine glass
I didn't like Colton has never found an
outdoor shower he doesn't like and
honestly I have no problem with that
he's showering he's outside great great
great I continue to say we're making up
lost time from last season now we're on
the beach we have the jungle behind us
we have the ocean in front of us
oh don't drink every time anyone says
that Thailand is beautiful a beautiful
place the beautiful issues mm-hmm don't
do it very dangerous no it is but think
of a different word you know who did
Sydney she called it feels like honey
primetime Realty picturesque it's super
romantic
Sydney picture asked sandy super
romantic
Cindy Wow how amazing somebody nailed
English Lit I like that Sydney she's
cool okay conversely and concerning
Leigh Hanna G did not nail geography
last episode we saw her wonder where
Singapore was and today she said I
didn't even think anything this dude
like she didn't think a resort like this
existed I don't know what that means
Hanna you didn't think that a resort
with buildings existed I'd just gonna
know about Google Hanna I like you I
like the lappet you've got a Google
stuff you know we all do it's hard it's
as hard as washing dishes people bop
[Music]
Heather
so Heather gets a one-on-one never been
kissed Heather oh my god that just made
me want to what's never been kissed when
you kiss someone everything you had and
she becomes hazy and the only thing in
focus is you and this person isn't
nobody
Jesse grossie Drew Barrymore on her
prime okay we won't tangents Lauren
tangents
however gets a one-on-one and Colton is
wearing a shirt that I wrote looks like
an old-timey kitchen tablecloth plus
flowers and it's a lot it was a lot
wasn't it drink every time you see a
flower on Colton's shirt or a
checkerboard pattern hmm I didn't drink
a lot last episode guys so I am here to
get this down to clear that it's a new
drinking bowl if I've ever heard one
so happy he's never kissed anyone but
man oh man is she nailed that running up
to Colton wrapping her legs around him
thing happens not messing around then we
cut back to wherever the heck they're
staying I was thinking this I wish that
they would give the place where the
contestants are outside and after the
mansion
like a name you know because we say the
mansion but then when they're in
Thailand I'm like the lobby I know where
they are let's say Elise is back in the
lobby of the resort the Hannah didn't
know anyway so Elise is back there and
oh my gosh just like Cassie kind of lost
it when Colton went on one last episode
Elise is now losing it the pressure is
getting to her clearly she had real
feelings for Colton but what did you
guys think of Elise's reaction to him
going on the other dates I always wonder
this it's like ladies didn't you know
what you signed up for
I love Elise though so what did you
think was she overreacting Elise said
something about like what do you get a
cookie but then
you are giving a cookie and then you go
back a couple of steps and then all I
could think about was that book if you
give him out the cookie if you give a
mouse a cookie he's going to ask for a
glass of milk yeah I'm talking about
like my childhood to give him I think
the premise was like we always want more
don't we if you give Lauren arose a
[Music]
cookies okay so Colton and Heather are
doing that thing that we do when we're
we're traveling we just like explore a
place so we say some of fun day ever to
like walk around no market we love
walking around a market for the whole
season don't drink every time somebody's
walking around a market they listen to a
show they hear hope
I can't be like I hear a bar in the
distance and there's hope at that bar
anyway I gotta give Colton as this was
funny Heather's never been kissed and
Colden asked her do you blow kisses
do i yeah like if she was okay with that
yeah okay good I was fighting cold then
we get a lot of like hinting tantalizing
foreshadowing zooms on Colton's lips but
it was probably we're eating and so I
didn't know if it was that tantalizing
you know they were eating noodles and
I've never looked at someone eating
noodles and thought I want to make out
with you right now
those are messy thing you know it's not
that lady in the [ __ ] poem that we all
hope for I don't kiss while eating
anyway
does anyone just finish your food will
our love survive so Cassie we then find
out is getting a one-on-one and she's so
happy but at least it's so sad and she
said when they did but Elise is so
emotionally destroyed this was so hard
to watch because I like both Cassie and
Elise and their emotions were in two
different places and it was difficult
and so what did I have to do I ended
right hmm get in there
JC yes too many jobs so many jobs he's
good at all though by the way JC still
single just saying everybody I see you
guys in the comments asking about him
he's a catch serious catch I want you to
know that I had an absolute blast
speaking of catches back to Colton
underway so Colton and Heather are at
dinner I know like the last time you
know we talked you told me about one of
your past relationships and she's trying
to explain why she's never kissed
someone high school I kind of dated
a bit like not really and call it took a
little bit here and there I gotta be
honest where you guys confused by this I
did not understand her stories I didn't
understand her reasoning I think that
she's really sweet I just didn't get it
she said something about dating someone
after college for eight months and he
was like literally he had everything I
run it on papers and they just never got
there I didn't really get it but it's
fine and I was also kind of confused by
what Colton was saying I'm concerned
about like that moment because that's
part of a relationship is just making
sure we're on the same page was he's
saying that they needed to be on the
same page and like they needed to kiss
cuz they needed to know if they had a
connection
I couldn't tell exactly what he was
getting across but I felt like if he was
saying that what Colton you want feel be
okay with you being a virgin so maybe
you go would have to be okay with dating
Hannah for eight months and not making
out with her then again we all know what
happens next so that doesn't happen I
think that we should go take a little
walk yeah okay so they're standing on a
beach chené they're staring at nothing
and then the fireworks scare them and
then what are you doing you're scared
you have your first kiss ever in life
that's what
[Music]
Heather cutter first kiss so that was
great quote of the night Heather I have
kissed a boy
[Music]
yay Heather I won I wish I had streamers
I wish it's confetti for you it's all I
got
I gotta keep these notes that want to
talk about yay Heather cheers - Heather
grabbing her first kiss did you think
that that was a solid move for Colton to
be Heather's first kiss she was under
the fireworks on TV why not I support it
and they changed her lower-third to has
been kissed
love those producers they're clever next
up we're back to emotionally destroyed
Elise and she is curling her hair and
they put this intense music to it and
all I could think was that she seems
like this seems like a scene an opening
scene in like an oxygen movie about a
woman who like kills all her husband's
like a black widow type of thing was
really intense and what was she doing
why is she crying her hair in the middle
of the night I had a lot of questions
don't drink every time at least says
work I know how much work can work just
as hard to make this work is it going to
work well I don't know we're gonna see
for some reason Elise is in a gown and
everyone else is in sweats and then
Heather comes back from her one-on-one
and says quote we went to a floating
island we went to a floating island
hello well Heather don't all islands
float I bet somebody's gonna call me out
of that there's probably something like
islands don't float they're like
attached to the ocean floor I don't know
anyway I don't care
but at least storms out away from the
women and oh my god she has gone to see
Colton in the night and I'm so excited
because it's been a minute since
somebody went to see the lead in the
middle of the night you know I feel like
we hadn't seen that moment a long time
on the show I wish I could just say that
there was something off between us
so Elyse is breaking up with Colton I
was so confused you guys did you think
that Elyse went there to break up with
him or did she go there hoping he would
tell her like you're the only one I want
and I'll you know just choose you right
here right now
there's a part of me that hoped I'd walk
in and they and you would just say like
but you would better and their
connections and even fine and we'd be
great friends or whatever it's like girl
you got to know at this point it's too
soon for him to do that you know he's
not gonna just pick you here and now
who's he the show what a season 23 I
love him she said and I can't call Chris
Harrison and say I want everyone on one
for the next year we wouldn't even have
anything to do with that filming is only
a few months Elyse so then she says you
really can't accept your proposal after
a few months that's literally the
premise okay so at least he's leaving
and I do not understand why she put this
dress on and curled her hair so
specifically to leave I didn't get it
I'd be like I gotta leave in my leggings
man because I'm about to get in the car
and then on a flight morally comfortable
imma break up with you in my sweats no
I'm saying just think about yourself and
poor Elise you guys how heartbreaking
was it to watch Elyse beat herself up
like that was Elise's exit upsetting to
you I felt so bad for her like do not
drink every time she criticizes herself
whoa
someone I care about I think just made a
really stupid mistake she was saying she
was disgusted with herself at least no
stupid am I
we love you you've been through a lot
and we love you I like Elise a lot I
know some of you are standing for her to
be Bachelorette I don't know I think
we've got a lot of season left to figure
out who that's gonna be
obviously but if it doesn't happen we'd
love to see them bachelor in paradise
I like Elise then we get another cold
with selfie video you know guys I've
been thinking about these selfie videos
more and look maybe they do give the
lead a chance to give some unique and
different personal insight and maybe I
just gotta accept them and that's it
nothing else to explain because this one
started out great today is Marie after I
had one-on-one with Heather and my
breakup abilities has never been a
sentence that's embodied the show more
like what a weird life place to be in I
just had a great first date with someone
and I broke up with someone
oh what's that in the same night so you
know maybe I like the selfie videos
maybe I'm turning I'm not but anyway the
jungles of Thailand and I thought there
was a Guns N'Roses part that was missing
here you know
welcome to the jungles of Thailand we
didn't wanna buy the rights to that
music all right where's Keith scenario I
can't cut it any spiders and snakes
cruel thing says they're gonna go to the
jungle we don't know why but he says
this is not a park this is not some
trail we are going through a jungle
we see them walking on a trail it's
right there in all the shots so it is
quite factually a trail anyway no high
cochin then we meet Joe it's not grocery
store Joe it's Jungle Joe it's a
different kind of way to find your food
and I thought if there's anybody who can
not only teach us how to survive out in
the jungle but to thrive it's Joe you
did you thought he would did you text
him did you know him before did you send
him an email no we don't have to pretend
like the lead is doing this Colton
doesn't know Joe he knows grocery store
Joe have you been to the jungle no okay
I show you around it's a survival date
and I was so excited for this you guys
because I've been hoping and asking for
a kind of bachelor naked and afraid
cross over do you guys watch me getting
afraid what look at that I love that
show it's fascinating that's a whole
other way of watching people develop
relationships you're naked in a
horrifying environment for 21 days with
no clothes no food no nothing those
people don't come out proposing you know
it's a yep that's water but this is kind
of the crossover I was hoping for so
great I'm in when they're not free but
not not shoot Edie draw Joe does things
like teach them to like elephant poop on
fire to survive we start the fire when
it's bright wow what's that smell like
ferocious animal in the jungle is Hannah
beast the women by the way drink every
time the women are killing it
Hanabi saw a bug hole Nicole grabbed an
evil Taoiseach hang it with a scorpion
need like crap these women are getting
after it and then you have Colton
running away from a snake that peed on
him cheers to the ladies hmm again I
would have actually just loved to see
them do naked and afraid like straight
up do it for a whole night
Wow that would have separated them I
don't know everybody but I love this oh
my god Demi I continue to love Devin you
guys you like Demi I love her so much
and I love her more with each episode
she and the two Hanna's decide that for
this group challenge where they have to
find food there's gonna get in van and
go to the hotel and get some cocktails
Jungle Joe is a very specific with the
rules digging around the jungle looking
for grubs cutting stuff open to try to
find water that just doesn't sound very
smart to me I mean I would eat a bug I'm
not afraid but I'm certainly certainly
gonna go get myself a tequila moment
with it they bring back burgers to the
jungle hilarious very smart of the
burger babes we know Colton loves his
food and you know what else gold likes
Taoiseach we move on to the rest of the
group date and Colton wants to give
Taoiseach some beach time alone just the
two of them he really likes her tisha is
coming out of the Woodworks since that
one-on-one date and I like her - I think
she's smart and really mature and I
Dictation what are yours think of
Taoiseach let me know
[Applause]
[Music]
Colton has some good convos with Hanabi
and she tells him that she is falling in
love with him a survival experience will
do that to a person it's like who are
you in love with the person I made it
out of the jungle with have you seen
castaway Hanna's Tom Hanks
I'm Colton's Wilson in this situation I
think Colton would be floating up to
seeing Hannah would have to get him was
it too soon for Hannah it's how cool and
she was falling in love with him let me
know I'm okay with it that falling in
love phrase is a safety net to make
you're not saying you're in love with
someone then on Jenka on Yaga pulling a
tattle-tale move I did not see this
coming
telling Colton this is confusing that
Elise told her I'm leaving that I need
to tell you something that Nicole told
me today
and she basically told me that Nicole
said that she's here so she can find an
opportunity to leave Miami I didn't get
that you know and also Italy here's the
thing I very rarely judge people's
motivations for going on these shows
anymore I mean if you're there totally
for fame that's one thing but I think at
the end of the day a lot of people go on
being like maybe I like this person and
I'll travel and meet some people and
like I want to have the experience I'm
okay with that perspective I don't mind
it but here's the thing about this whole
interaction I had a lot of feelings very
quickly very up and down because my
prediction that Nicole was gonna be like
we I wanted to just come here and you
know see what happened no I was wrong
and things changed very quickly in this
narrative
so well you know Elise and she's a
really honest person on Jaeger
tattletales to Colton about the thing
that at least told her about Nicole
but then when Colton confronts Nicole
about it Nicole straight-up denies it
and I can be further from the truth
thank you this is not an opportunity to
be Miami and then tisha clears it up I
did not see that coming says she heard
the conversation between a Lisa Nicole
no no no like she never said that she
needs to get out of Miami for me right
that's not what Nicole said so Anika
unknowingly seemingly just lied to Cole
just told him something totally false
and you guys think that I'm Yuka should
have gone to Nicole first and asked her
about it I do I do I do I do
so then I'm wondering why does Dan Yager
just apologize to Nicole well then oh my
god Don Yenko grabs a martini for her
ITM and says she's sick of how much
Nicole is crying Cara is literally every
single day I start to think I'm gay cos
just wanting Nicole out of here isn't
she is she is was this all a ploy what
do you guys think was on Jenka being
manipulative or trying to do the right
thing mmm I'm so unfazed by her tears
like I literally cannot deal yes
Hanabi will you accept this rose
and then Hanabi gets the rose you never
get the rose and you're part of that
back and forth thing you know she said
she's come a long way and I agree are
you guys turning a tide on Hanabi now
after the her and Kaylin drama settled
I like canopy I always thought that she
was getting a little bit of the of a bad
rap there because she's just a more like
emotional outspoken personality but I
think I like and then we have Cassie's
one-on-one and man do not drink every
time somebody gets on a boat on this
episode nobody's wearing life jackets
life jacket they don't look good but
don't want to die so tasse is saying
that colton gives her butterflies
butterflies in my stomach remember her
entrance butterflies and coldness saying
he's smitten with Cassie difference.we
my destiny
he really likes that word but I also
think these two really like each other
they get their own private island is
this the naked and afraid' crossover
I've been waiting for here's the thing
they tried to snow it's a private island
but it was just a pile of sand what were
they supposed to do there I just kept
thinking to me get us back do they get a
champagne do they get a towel do you
think it's sunscreen do they get water
okay
and I mean that survival he got nothing
no plants to forage no poop to burn yeah
maybe your own you don't have a lighter
anyway so the thing is as concerned as I
am for Colton and Cassie's health and
well-being they do seem to have a
connection they are making out in the
water and it is sexy Colton did that
thing where he grabs her face oh you
know that means somebody really likes
somebody and they really connect and
talk about your acted they are to each
other and then they're back at the hotel
and they talk about how they feel like
they've known each other for forever and
then they're in bed together oh my god
like I gotta say gold is a virgin I feel
like there's somebody to me in his bed
that's kind of a big deal even if
nothing really happened so wait what did
you guys think of Colton and Cassie's
connection all the other ladies were
saying it's strong and I agree my
favorite part is that Colton said quote
my hardest I wish to go off my heart is
telling me just to go on
[Music]
distance okay Celine I love a Celine
Dion reference he had snakes to fear and
he knows that he will get Peter
[Music]
they're just drinkin sing I think I've
peaked I'm gonna go home rose ceremony
you guys you guys you guys this curve
I'll have a band-aid on her chin that
has never explained this is the last
thing he wants to deal with or think
about I was so concerned for her every
time they cut towards this bandaid on
her chin I was it can we understand what
happened is she okay chip a fortune on
some spot in bed like that chicken guy
I'm Becca cooling season I was worried
don't drink every time you see her chin
man Dave I don't want a boyfriend I
don't want an Instagram husband I don't
want anything like that I'm looking for
a partner in life
so Nicole sits down with Colton and says
she is not too here for the wrong
reasons
she is not here for an Instagram husband
and I have to say I think that might be
like one of the first times we've ever
heard the show talk about Instagram and
I'm here for it let's acknowledge the
reality of our situation there's
something else now Nicole is saying oh
my god she's taking this conflict to the
next level it's continuing that on Yakka
has been bullying her this whole time
Anika has been bullying me ever since
the moment I have met her my head is on
a swivel with these two more than Jamie
and Tracy more than demi and Courtney I
can't keep track on Yaga and Nicole
whose side are you on
are you just exhausted of it I think we
all were on Jaeger then sits down and
confront sickle and says when have I
called you mentally unstable
so name one time I called you mentally
unstable it's emotionally unstable you
know who looks stable here pretty much
no okay nobody's coming out with a great
don't drink every time they say bully
hmm I'm gonna finish this for my
survival I'm gonna cool things down
golden walks over to them and they both
go dead silence I got a break cuz I can
hold my eyes open really long I'm like
illegally blind and I have contacts and
so they're like really 50 my eyes open a
long time and we end with Colton being
over it and next week everyone is crying
and next week everyone is oily and I
love when we get a to be continued and I
love this episode you guys what did you
think best one yet let me know and now
it's time to go so I had nothing to fear
because I know that my wine glass goes
on it's so dirty okay anyways you guys
as always thank you so much for watching
JC thank you for being JC is single
just say he's looking for somebody to go
on the journey with he's laughing I
don't you guys could hear you audibly
laugh just then thank you so so much for
watching leave your comments below
this season is awesome and you guys are
awesome I love you so much
also remember every Tuesday morning we
are going to have a bachelor
bachelorette bachelor in paradise guests
or alum or someone who has just recently
kicked off the season of The Bachelor on
et live to do an interview with them so
check those out I love you so much
let me see how long I can keep my eyes
open okay you tell me when I'm hoping I
guess of where I came and talk
my contacts start to lift off of my eyes
that's what's happening right now and
vision blanked by the way this was JC's
idea brilliant and I believe that ABC
has now released a deleted scene
explaining what happened to kirpa